[Applause]
the biden administration expressed
cautious hope that peace may be enduring
following the ceasefire declared by the
ethiopian government into cry
but there was a warning about human
rights abuses and a commitment that the
u.s would act
if it was judged that efforts toward a
political settlement were being hampered
we will not stand by in the face of
horrors in tigre
though robert godick did not elaborate
throughout the congressional hearing
ethiopia's position as a key us
ally in the region was emphasized even
as witnesses and members of congress
outlined the abbey government's
responsibility for human rights abuses
and malnutrition
if i leave you with one thing today it
is that usaid believes
famine is likely already occurring in
ethiopia the chairman of the foreign
affairs committee was emphatic
what we are seeing unfolding to gray
bears the hallmarks of crimes
against humanity and quite possibly
a genocide but ethiopia is seen as
key to the us's strategic objectives in
africa
and meeks tempered his criticism of the
ethiopian prime minister
prospects for a durable peace in
ethiopia and its role as a responsible
regional leader
are now in question as
is prime minister's abi's legacy
on the ground to ground forces the tplf
said they had the regional capital
mckele fully under their control and
there were celebrations in the town of
shire amid reports that eritrean troops
had left
the tplf also vowed to push south and
east to consolidate its position
notably it has not announced a ceasefire
the us
is treading carefully washington has
been trying to preserve all
options with respect to its engagement
with
with ethiopia uh they've been trying to
use
uh diplomatic persuasion up to this
point to get the ethiopian government to
relent
in its sort of pursuit of total victory
in
gray um they have not been successful in
in that conversation
but they have withheld some of the most
biting sanctions that the united states
has sanctions related to the human
rights
abuses that have gone on uh at the hands
of ethiopian
government troops and their allies in
the region it's clear that the biden
administration wants to keep the
ethiopian government close
especially as china extends its reach
across
africa but there are reports that some
members of congress will be keeping a
close eye on prime minister abiya's
actions
especially as they weigh the us's
foreign aid budget
shia britancy al jazeera capital him